I don't want to argue I didn't want to
come on here and argue with the guest
you're not arguing you're not really
arguing and we respectfully you're
respectfully I respect everyone's
opinion I really do I just have a
different opinion well that's fine but
if your opinion is closed the beach down
in my opinion is I want to go the
[ __ ] beach then I should go to the
beach I agree with you I agree but he
wasn't allowed to but I wasn't allowed
to go to the beach that's at the
beginning we didn't know they never and
look you're not an epidemiologist if you
can't [ __ ] figure out that going to
the beach is not a bad place to go with
a virus that's insane but I'm not an
epidemiologist and I was just going
based on what I did know you listen to
people that shut the beaches down I
didn't listen to them I knew they were
wrong and they were wrong so in your own
house your wife must have been afraid
for your own children your children's
school no we have healthy kids it
doesn't affect kids I mean but she was
okay with leaving them home or she
wanted them to go back to school
like we'll do whatever they they tell us
to do they're not great students
up a lot of kids I believe you that I
think it did and I think that hindsight
is 20 20. but you're saying I agree
hindsight is 2020 but they knew a lot of
this stuff earlier than but the problem
is that we all can't get on the same
page and the reason is that we don't all
have and I think it's algorithms we
don't all have the same we have the same
Source sources for information but it
isn't funneled that way because of
social media if you look at social media
now you get the information that you
have clicked on that you have enjoyed
you're getting different information
than I'm getting
well what I did during the whole
pandemic is I watched social media and
then I watched who they pulled off of
social media and the people they pulled
off of social media were many doctors
many guys with some pretty rich
pedigrees from Stanford and Harvard and
all that kind of stuff and they were
pulling these guys off for
disinformation and I kept watching the
pattern like why is everyone who
disagrees with the status quo even
though these are people with
Decades of experience in the field why
are they all being pulled off but are
they really being paid off yeah you know
you know not to take a side well they
were yeah but but even on public uh
television you know like the the uh the
difference between Fox and CNN they were
both there for the
taking nobody shut any one of them down
one of them's got to be wrong
right yeah no well you can't shut down
Fox but you can shut down you know
there's a doc uh sorry there's a
journalist named Alex Berenson and he
write he used to write for the New York
Times and stuff and he started writing a
bunch of stories about it and he was
pulled off of Twitter but he was right
about everything and turned out to be
right about everything is he back on
Twitter no he's suing Twitter and I
don't know if he's back on Twitter but
the point is is most the people that had
opposing viewpoints were removed from
Twitter or many were and I found that
curious I'm like why are they taking
down guys who dis you know so they say
lock it down one group of doctors says
shut schools the other group of doctors
says this is a mistake we shouldn't be
locking things down and the ones who say
it's a mistake were the ones who were
de-platformed and I found that curious I
was like why are they why isn't this an
open form where everyone can have their
their opinions especially since they're
both experts so it became
apparent to me that there was a pattern
that was forming and that pattern was
there was a kind of an Orthodoxy like
mask up everywhere and if you said masks
aren't effective then you got into
trouble and pulled down and so I started
focusing on who was being pulled down
and why they're being pulled down I'm
not talking about like Fringe weird you
know tinfoil hat guys I'm talking about
doctors and epidemiologists who are
sharing their opinions and that's when I
started to see that something was going
on
you didn't believe in a mask now why
well I flew a lot during the pandemic
right and did you ever get covered
I don't think so but I'm not you didn't
get tested
the answers maybe I've been tested you
know I have you had syphilis
we can talk after that okay you flew a
lot I flew a lot and the second they
said you know the second I flew the
first time and they handed me the
Mediterranean hummus box for for lunch
and they said you can take the mask off
and eat and then you got to put the mask
back on when you're done eating or
here's your drink you can take the mask
on take the mask off in between sips and
then you got to pull the mask up after
each sip I was like oh this doesn't do
anything this is total [ __ ] doesn't
make any sense there's no app you either
wear a mask or you don't wear a mask yes
plus half the people I saw wearing the
mask had the strap Twisted yeah and when
you twist the strap that goes around
your ear it leaves about a 7 8 Gap it
like bunches up and leaves this big air
gap so you can literally see the
person's cheek through their thing and
I'm like this is an Airborne virus this
is this is this isn't doing anything you
don't think that it's a little bit of a
deterrent for that Airborne environment
I mean it makes it makes sense that it's
a little bit of a deterrent but I don't
think the statistics really bear that
out but even if it even if it is
I ever so I see I also started talking
to people
like being of Kevin and Bean right and
he said I did everything right I did
everything right and I got covered I
wore masks I've washed everything down
you know beans kind of in your Camp you
know what I mean he's he's a hand washer
he said I did everything right and I got
this i got this thing and I started
talking to a lot of people and went I
did everything they told me to do and I
got coveted and then I was like I've
done nothing they've told me to do and I
haven't gotten covid and then my friend
who I travel with Mike August he's done
nothing either and he didn't get coveted
so it became apparent to me very early
that you're gonna get it or you weren't
gonna get it right or you're probably
were gonna get it and your best defense
is exercise and sunshine and a good diet
and then you probably would get it and
so with that in mind I was like
I'm just going to throw caution in the
wind I'm going to travel I'm not washing
my hands and I'm going to take care of
business and then if I get it I'll get
it but I didn't see any logical way to
prevent me from getting it since
everyone who did all the logical stuff
didn't it didn't seem to prevent them
from getting it my problem with that
train of thought is you you're like oh
I'll just throw caution to the wind and
get it which is great for you because
you are healthy and relatively young and
you could fight it like you're saying
and it's no big deal it might just be
like a cold or a flu or nothing at all
but then you're traveling around and
seeing all these other people that are
susceptible to maybe
more
harmful effects of it well then they
need to stay home oh you're for the
you're in the camp of like if you're
older you stay home well if you're
susceptible or what how however you
described it if you're a person that is
old or has pre-existing conditions or
something then you need to take care of
that
okay well let's stop staring at me dad
stop okay if you're in danger yeah I
mean if if you're in that group then you
need to act accordingly I wouldn't fly
commercially
you know you're talking about and that's
willing to piss in a sink no I know I
know well all helping I'm a hand washer
I'm a hand washer I'm not but but the
Apple didn't fall far from the sink if
you but if you say all help each other I
I no one's going to disagree with all
help each other but shut down tons of
businesses in schools in society then
that's not all helping each other I
agree with that damage was done yeah I
agree with that I'm not arguing with
well like I have elderly parents I
wouldn't but you hate them I I well I'm
not a fan but it's a two-way street they
should stay at home see it's different
it was more important to me to be able
to see my parents and hang out with my
parents and my kids see my parents then
me go and possibly get it but I don't
see we're working under the supposition
that you can not get it I don't know
that you cannot get it I know well you
cannot get it if you
everyone everyone has got it I mean no
but you could not get it by locking
yourself away not going to school not
going out on wood I don't even know if
you cannot get it that way I mean
honestly well the truth of the matter is
your son got it and I did not yeah and
he barfed in my face wow yeah he
literally barfed in my face oh like like
all over yeah some guys are into that
yeah
foreign
[Music]